[Música]
hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo américa edición nocturnas está
con nosotros jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches vamos a comenzar en europa
que este continente comienza a
reaccionar a esta suspensión del
suministro de gas ruso para dos
integrantes de la unión europea bulgaria
y polonia
úrsula von der leyen quien es presidente
de la comisión europea dijo que las
empresas energéticas europeas no deben
acceder a las demandas de rusia moscú
exige pagar sus facturas en rublos pero
con der leyen advierte que quienes
accedan estarían violando las sanciones
europeas contra moscú incurrirían en un
alto riesgo en la unión europea
alrededor del 97 por ciento de todos los
contratos se estipulan los pagos en
euros o dólares exceptuando algunos
casos escuchemos que dijo la presidenta
hoy
y ones hoy el kremlin ha fracasado una
vez más en su intento de sembrar la
división entre los estados miembros la
era del combustible fósil ruso en europa
está llegando a su fin europa avanza en
materia energética
santiago y es que un informe del centro
de investigación sobre energía y aire
limpio que publica hoy the guardian
afirma que rusia casi ha duplicado sus
ingresos por la venta de combustibles
fósiles a la unión europea según el
reporte rusia ha recibido alrededor de
62 mil millones de euros de las
exportaciones de petróleo gas y carbón
solamente en los 2 meses desde que
comenzó la invasión europa importó 44
mil millones de euros en los últimos 2
meses en comparación con los 140 mil
millones de todo el año pasado los datos
simplemente muestran como rusia continúa
beneficiándose de la venta de los
hidrocarburos pese a estas sanciones que
han impuesto ya hablemos ahora del
impacto que tiene en américa latina
porque sabemos que los efectos de la
guerra impactan fuertemente a europa
pero cómo está afectando a américa
latina' esta semana preparamos una serie
para analizar a fondo como en algunos
países latina se están sintiendo estos
efectos del turno hoy es para perú cuyos
agricultores están padeciendo un fuerte
aumento en los precios de los
fertilizantes nuestro corresponsal en
lima francisco zacarías nos amplia más
desde hace más de 30 años leoncio
bizarre se dedica a la agricultura
único
este agricultor es uno de los más de 2
millones de peruanos que trabaja en el
campo y que sufre el incremento actual
en el costo de los fertilizantes ha
subido todo va en dólares en dólares por
decir que antes compramos un saco de
abono para que 20 dólares ahora 64
dólares rusia fue el principal proveedor
de fertilizantes en perú el 2021 más del
64 4% de urea importada provino de la
nación rusa al igual que el 98 por
ciento del nitrato de amonio ambos son
los abonos químicos más usados gracias a
nosotros pueden comer en la ciudad
sucre - agrarios calculan que van a
tener una pérdida de más del 60% en sus
ganancias y para evitar que continúe la
caída total bien al gobierno de pedro
castillo retornar a la forma de cultivo
que realizaban los incas una de las
propuestas de nosotras dentro de ello es
decir por qué no también en general todo
lo abono orgánico porque no generar
darle esta viabilidad
alternativa a nuestro país a los
pequeños productores darle darle esa
sabiduría con fuerza a nuestras abuelas
a nuestras áreas mientras tanto los
costos en el campo repercuten en la
canasta familiar
390 productos subieron de precio desde
que se inició la guerra siendo los de
mayor alza verduras y hortalizas según
cifras oficiales maribel rivadeneira
antes gastaba cerca de 7 dólares diarios
para cocinar el almuerzo de su familia
ahora paga el doble y el dinero no le
alcanza todo ahorita está muy caro y qué
pasa que los niños estamos reaccionando
la comida a los niños y los niños que
los niños solamente te piden te dice
mamá tengo hambre y tú tienes que ver la
manera de darme de comer o buscar la
manera de de darle su comida a ellos o
no mientras se ejecutan nuevas medidas
para proteger a los agricultores negocio
bizarre está montando una pequeña tienda
cambiar de giro es la única alternativa
para defenderse de la crisis para que su
familia pueda tener sustento
jorge ya hablamos ahora de la república
centroafricana uno de los países más
pobres del continente africano y adoptó
el bitcoin como una moneda oficial de
curso legal de esta forma santiago se
convierte en el primer país de áfrica y
el segundo en el mundo en hacerlo pese a
su riqueza en oro y diamantes la
república centroafricana es uno de los
países más pobres como bien decías y
menos desarrollados del mundo de
septiembre del año pasado el salvador se
convirtió en el primer país del mundo en
adoptar el bitcoin como moneda en curso
de legal
hablemos ahora de la empresa de drones
que suspendió temporalmente sus
actividades en rusia y en ucrania por
supuesto por la guerra esta empresa dijo
que no quiere que sus drones sean
utilizados en el conflicto lo cierto es
que muchas marcas y empresas
occidentales se retiraron del mercado
ruso luego de la invasión de moscú a
ucrania pero las firmas chinas han
seguido operando en el país beijing
evita criticar públicamente a rusia por
el conflicto dj se convierte en una de
las pocas compañías chinas que suspende
actividades en rusia y probablemente sea
la primera porque muchas gracias por
esta actualización de las noticias
destacadas del mundo de la economía la
continuación estamos listos para el
debate aquí en directo américa edición
nocturna
[Música]